est-ce que vous êtes prêts oui en finale
au final on joue pas donc voilà
exactement à bien vous en sus le gagnant
de benjamin exact attention c'est moi
qui ai dit si bas résille lequel de ces
artistes à représenter la france à
l'eurovision quatre propositions là mais
en gal avec des branches l'âme avec
chanter pour ceux qui sont loin de chez
eux cyril hanouna avec bob d'abord
d'hanovre où jesse matador avec allez
ola olé tueur n ont pas ben non je suis
qualifié moi la réponse est dédé la
réponse est dédé et il y a une mauvaise
réponse qu'est ce qui se passe ça ne
l'est pas je connaissais pas j'ai sorti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à temps pour tout le monde sauf pour
cette année c'est pas cette personne on
bat sophie soi disant révolution
s'il vous plaît ces murs attention pas
un truc s'il se faisait attaquer non
mais je me mets mon nom je me fais
encore été annoncé mais on a sonné hier
vous avez gagné ou perdu
alors quand on perd on est champions là
aussi c'est oui ouais bah justement
justement on voulait arriver en finale
je vous dis ça parce qu'il ya plein de
mecs qui vont vouloir lui voler son truc
à lui c'est rien de le jeter tout
naturel la publicité en question
attention si elle est l'impératif du
verbe alors là c'est peu attention
qu'elle est l'impératif du verbe feindre
à la première personne du pluriel petit
à feignons petit b sainton coty ces
feignasses sortent pas un tout petit
définition du verbe feindre vaincre way
to frein dry fin de frein à toute la
première personne du pluriel et vous me
dites à il n'y a que des bonnes réponses
[Applaudissements]
fédérer d'égaler ses querelles également
d'un coin tu vois tu rates ton retour tu
ton retard sophie c'est bien dans le
film de 1995 des anges gardiens qui
partage l'affiché avec gérard depardieu
pierre richard en a
daniel auteuil en b christian clavier en
c ou une bouteille de bordeaux en d1
vous me répondre et vous me dire c'est
pour nom est libre de la ccm haqqani
j'en ai aucune idée aucune idée tu
connais pas le femise ans gardien non ça
te dirait jamais généré sans clavier ils
avaient leur double jamais fines
d'amiante à rien non mais c'est un fait
95 c'est pas son truc
elle a répondu quoi elle arrête on l
avait répondu à trois noms j'ai fait ce
qu'on aurait pu et su redonner leur
attention juste alors il ya deux
personnes en cire là
hajjar hiver premier degré sur le jeu
cooper 1er degré oui elle et les amis
sont un petit peu en retard mais c'est
rien c'est juste un point kelly et
sophie alors quand même question il ya
il ya huit questions vous avez tous fait
moins les foules et la regarder le
cheminot un petit dieu qu'est la halle à
aller en france alors attention c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué à son
fermi d'ailleurs à des amis d'amis
combien on va savoir si vous êtes de
quatre mois qu'il est prêt en france le
panneau routier qui annonce un danger
temporaire temporaire non j'ai fait un
triangle rouge avec à l'intérieur une
photo de gilles verdez noir du jaune ou
du orange temporaire du noir attention
memphis et hanouna les crs qui c'est
arrivé passé trois fois celle qui ont
marqué et on n'y fait pas il est
pourtant qui la retient un permis vous
parce que je conduisais le zizi à l'est
[Rires]
m
[Applaudissements]
vous avez tous oui j'avais tous bien
triché en même temps pas nos alliances
changent mais pas en plus c'est faux
c'est la bonne que c'est pas leur truc
était on peut me remettre les les
réponses là qui a mis des mois jeu vidéo
et ben voilà série la luna merci voilà
alain larouche qui tire sur le jaune
ouais en tout cas vous aviez misé b
c'était un ami noir
ouais rien à voir rien à voir rien à
voir non ils sont daltoniens ivoiriens
aussi un peu la très noir au milieu mois
à l'autre et noir sinon ta gueule ah non
mais c'est normal elle est longue elle
arrive en diligence n'a pas peur on a
parlé de dix ans est ce que vous savez
ce que c'est qu'une alouettes une
alouette s'étonner de ce tome une quête
morts d'oiseaux
voilà les vraies mais franchement avoir
avoir un élève comme ça en classe mais
mais franchement c'est une à droite
c'est comme une quête mans noiseau voilà
mon bassin oiseaux effectivement et donc
c'est une question à propos des
alouettes
lorsqu'une alouettes chante oui on peut
aussi dire quel petit indice elle fait
comme isabelle alors justement est-ce
qu'elle turlutte est-ce qu'elle pète
comme benjamin s quelques n comme je ne
sais pas qui vous est ce qu elle le vrai
tu allais alors qui a la bonne réponse
normalement il est super fort tant en
animaux j'aurais dit sur lui toujours
pas vite
[Applaudissements]
hier encore il reste encore en dessous
de choc l'un son portable alors
attention à la barbe je vais bien la
prochaine émission les brêmois si vous
vous n'avez rien à faire après
malheureusement je bosse alors vous le
posez là je le mail arrivant devant
opposer l'as jamais là on dit que dans
le peau et vous leur tournée non non
c'est vous que je vais retourner les
compositions
[Applaudissements]
c'est là qu'on connaît je ne savais
proches mais pas à ce point là
vous savez qu'en ce moment il ya une
promotion sur pour 3 e bol de bogues
petit bol de foie gras frais voilà
acheter on a une écharpe de regard sur
les toits et ce à trois points les eaux
tous quatre points et en tête cyril
hanouna à cinq points
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je te prends du miel pour isabelle c'est
pour vous ça mais vous connaissez la
harissa
bien sûr la camisa voilà l'origine du
mot harissa est à lhassa qui signifie
petit à mg oro id petit bé oui mon petit
c'est broyé ou petits des relevés est ce
que vous êtes bon en langue étrangère
alors vous invite vivement à petit b
pour être alors là on a quasiment on a
là bas du broyer boyer boyer broyer la
bonne réponse était broyée bravo
essayez encore et encore à bord du monde
avance alors là là là là j'avoue la
question était fait pour moi c'est un
peu facile
un peu pour moi j'ai l'ancienne et
bernard n'est pas marocain fait des uv
connaît bernard né au maroc où il est né
ouais c'est pas parce que castaldi a une
bouche que c'est un chameau
c'est maintenant si vous voulez passer
en deuxième manche à 15 ans parce que là
il reste plus que deux questions
attention madame mais c'est moi c'est
pour ça que je le dis pas qu'ils vont
être encore humiliée une deuxième fois
c'est pas c'est parfois il sait ce que
je dis donc six points pour cyril
descours gilles et jean mi les autres
sont à 4 points et se fie à trois points
attention là tout peut à nouveau willis
et ray le café le plus cher du monde est
très content on me dit tu as des
excréments de civette au tibet l'égérie
régurgitation d'okapi petit c'est de
leur hymne de gerbilles derby ou petit
des eaux non le slip de bain jean marie
va au nom des excréments du site
attention qu'est ce que vous me dites
très important ce point là on savoir qui
moi je vas aller en vieille deuxième
manche gerry curtis après vous avez dit
vous êtes tous à me dire les excréments
de s'y mettent aussi
frémont raymond lives de l'uriné il veut
de lui rythme et non vraiment c'est les
excréments bras
les enfants si lille a encore bien
répondu ça fait qu'ils aient en tête à
sept points mais tout peut se jouer sur
cette dernière question
là encore il ya quand même deux
candidats jean michel et gilles qui sont
à six points
il vous colle au cul si je remercie les
quatre premiers califes et donc moi je
suis qualifié vous êtes qualifiés vous
êtes qualifiés attendait kombila commun
qu'est 10,5 points
elle est pour l'instant les trois à cinq
pour le seul truc qui est sûr c'est que
sophie et raymond way ne sais pas
maigrir ou quoi voilà donc raymond tu
peux aller tout de suite livrés c'est
sûr et c'est sur le triangle 1 qu'il a
foiré aller voilà c'est pas centré sur
plein de bon les amis attention et que
vous vous y connaissez en alcool en
uranium en or et en sable la boue
julien labouche l'uranium du reich
l'uranium à l'uranium l'or l'alcool
l'uranium le sable dans le sang humain
on trouve en moyenne rôle de 0,2 mg d'or
alors 12 grammes d'alcool l'hérault 2 5
mg d'uranium ou 0,3 mg de sable alors à
bien dire que c'est une question sur le
radium
je suis qualifié et vous me dites dit
bruce place et le radium
mais vous êtes nude non c'est que vous
croyez tous les genres oui oui c'était
lors on a toujours vu en lui fait un
kilo d'or mais c'est pas drôle c'est pas
dans le sens et les chocs offre non à
l'abandon lors les avancées les 7,2 ce
n'est pas une série mutation non ça veut
dire qu'on a tous jérôme bonaldo leurs
adolescents mais l'évêque mais moi mais
je vais faire une prise de sang tout à
l'heure je le récupère on va vendre tous
alors non je fais du salon sont
qualifiés pour l'instant il ya quelqu'un
qui se dit très bonnes ventes qualifiées
pour l'instant les amis tir il est
qualifié
gilles est qualifié et gens me et
qualifié les trois vous êtes qualifiés
maintenant il va falloir départager
kelly mais novelli ok si is a woman a ou
bien bernard bazille montbernard vous
êtes tous les trois à avoir 5 et vous
jouez pour votre place dans la deuxième
manche
attention c'est une question chiffre est
d'accord donc alors est comment comment
est ce qu'ils font là parce que pour la
question chiffré du sac à chaque arrêt
pour d'accord alors on va qu'on va
commencer
combien y at-il de communes en france
honneur aux jeunes fini on va commencer
par kelly
combien y at-il de communes communes
36000 à peu près 36000 communes vous me
dites très bien le note isabelle alors
j'en suis foutrement rien quarante mille
40 milles
je dirais 121000 121000 la bonne réponse
était 34 1967 guerre
[Applaudissements]
ça valait lunar wheel et convenir il est
content alors c'est vrai je peux prendre
à cet échec et loser donc désolé mais
surtout amusez vous avez joué comme la
dernière question la mitaine face à
lille est qualifiée puisque les
tablettes c'est fascinant coeur regarde
ça va sinon vois tu diras ce à deux
c'est toujours ce qu'ils sont c'est
toujours ceux qui perdent qui se
plaignent sont qualifiés le concours
bulan là qui tourne au taux de crédit
soient levés il fait ce qu'il veut c'est
un peu le produit candidat mais vous
avez droit trouvait aussi la gueule
cyril hanouna jean-michel mère kelly b2b
dit gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
dézinguer les animaux en deuxième manche
vous n'êtes plus que 4 8m vont
apparaître à l'écran
d'accord le meilleur de la première
manche qui va choisir donc un des thèmes
et il va répondre en premier
je rappelle que vous aurez une minute
pour répondre aux questions
puis ensuite le deuxième prendra le
deuxième tome est 3e 3g le thème etc etc
cyril quel thème vous choisissez moi
j'aimerais bien les voir alors vous avez
et que je ni sexy technologies annoncé
six mois si oui alors fiction je sais
que c'est ma spécialité n'étant avec nos
logis également ouais vous pouvez être
aussi stratège pas arts martiaux non non
non il a par là la vie civile si je peux
me permettre
beaucoup d'annoncés lexus ça c'est sûr
je sais pas je suis pas du tout sera des
mois mené patratas d'accord et nos
victoires de victoire la victoire parce
qu'on peut aussi prendre un truc on a un
peu moins fort mais sachant que l'autre
est beaucoup plus vraiment un truc où je
suis moins fort là dedans alors
attention là il va perdre pas mal et
c'est lorsqu'elle a c'est une minute en
face à venir
rires
je te montre tiens j'aimerais juste un
truc j'en rigolais vous en croit rien je
le monte ce nom quelqu'un vous attaque
non mais non mais on m'attendait je te
montre la magie quelqu'un voilà ici la
personne tarak chérif impression c'est
terminé il immobilise terrils à la duke
serrer les coudes des mois en tête la
tête une minute alors vraiment d'être
concentré sur du sexy sur du sexy quand
vous avez une minute au bénin ebook et
howie olemps et naïm montre moi et
pourquoi devons nous revoir pour tous et
que germaine quand je le tiens vous
donner envie je vais te réponde aux dés
je referai panneaux de façon sexy
barcarès encore howie benhaim sa
catégorie s'il montre moi ta chatte
avoir battu cypher
un débat avait lavé dream si vous ne
savez pas vous dites je passerai
d'accord on a cherché à donner la
réponse attention 3 1
quelle mauvaise concert récemment non
c'est être héritier d'une partie de la
fortune de karl lagerfeld chez bic au
nickel sous vêtements portent un nom
américain que l'on peut traduire par
ficelles à tring qu'elle était miss
france que clémence bottines auquel
lettres de l'alphabet de frais associés
aux films pornos x en quelle année fut
comme ça viser la première mini jupe en
1962 oui quel couple fut surnommé
brangelina brad pitt angelina jolie
bravo combien d le titre cette chanson
de serge gainsbourg sea sex and sun
oui ok en france à quelle date et
célébrer la fête des amoureux 14 février
oui quels artistes à l'origine le
tableau l'origine du monde
ses courbes et oui en quelle année fut
lancé le concours de miss univers
je ne sais pas c'est vivant à 52 quel
ouvrage est censé recenser toutes les
positions sexuelles
gamasutra oui vrai ou faux pas je
partais de forme moyen va prochainement
sortir un calepin sexy faut qu'elle soit
bonne et sur le sex symbol surnommée la
madone madone madonna oui dans quelles
villes italiennes se déroule l'action
principale du reuz du roman roméo et
juliette donc c'est un verrou qui chante
le titre sex bomb sex bomb james ward
non non non j'aime bien tom jones
quel beau gosse tient le rôle principal
dans le film thor crimes suspects
[Applaudissements]
c'était tout à l'heure et je leur en
suis trompé c'est qui déjà 14 points sur
quoique 15 ou 16 couleurs très bien en
fuite on m'avait en deuxième position je
crois que c'était eux gilles girard
d'avenir da c'était juste derrière moi
ouais c'est ça j'ai senti son pipi c'est
bon si vous reste états unis et
technologies années 2000 art personnage
de fiction sciences ou séries je vais
prendre états unis y a pas eu ou non
n'est pas y'a pas fatou gillett que vous
vous sentez de maths rssi rilke
absolument pas rétorque chimot baby art
est mieux je vais faire de mon mieux
lors ce mois c'est énorme et non sa fin
tout on va se on va se concentrer et on
y va
allez on va mal on y va alors attention
gilles ses prêts une lutte top dans quel
état des usa se déroule à ses rivaux
corte texas ranger path to texas
oui quelle est la traduction littérale
du mot cowboys éleveur de vaches
oui garçons de vache quelle est la durée
du mandat d'un président américain
quatre ans oui au large de quelle grande
ville se trouve la prison d'alcatraz san
francisco oui les etats unis sont nommés
le pays de l'oncle sam
oui quel monument américain a été frappé
par un attentat le 11 septembre 2001
world trade center week-end président
américain à présent sur le billet de 100
dollars les l'école non franklin quel
pays va prochainement être séparé des
états unis par un mur le mexique
oui vrai ou faux à des états américains
a pour devise on a tous en nous quelque
chose de tennessee fond d'idées bien y
at il deux bandes rouges et blanches sur
le drapeau américain
18 16 l'an 13 de quelle ville
hollywoodienne est il au niveau des
kills un quartier los angeles
oui quel animal peut voir sur le grand
saut des etats-unis peut-on voir j'ai
pas compris sur l'animal peut-on voir ce
qu'on leur en sont des états unis
l'aigle oui mais quel tiko signifie le
sigle fbi aux investigations ouiais ce
quelles villes américaines est surnommée
la grosse pomme new york
oui
c'est beau l'amitié une réponse isabelle
m'a soufflé fort
la belle a soufflé fou déjà c'est
peut-être son dernier souffle ont la
peau et tu gagnes ce point vous savez
quoi
ce que je propose c'est que on découvre
les deux autres finalistes
juste après la pub parce que maintenant
ça va être l'heure de touche pas à mon
poste mais encore continuer évidemment
parce qu'il en a besoin de savoir sur
ben oui nous n'allons pas que cela dure
un peu plus besoin de benhaim voilà moi
j'ai juste une question
voilà je non pas du tout oui je
j'appelle la direction est ce que là je
vais être pas ni en tant que chroniqueur
après également voilà c'est juste pour
savoir donc mettez vous d'accord vous
avez le temps de la pub et ensuite mois
après il y aura un finaliste face à
benjamin castadi évidemment bien sûr du
suroît de l'allemagne connaît d'uranus
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous alors didier valade est
plus qu est la salle yedaya
mais sans déconner belge arrive tu vois
pas 50 50 ans parce que les préfixes
presto ben ouais merci d'être avec un
fait de gloire on est en direct bien là
denis la regardez là là là assis tout le
maghreb et les séries on est très agitée
vous le savez là on est en plein
concours les chroniques on exactement
pour l'instant pour l'instant peut-être
vous voyez remarques acerbes à un
casting est qualifié oui il a gagné hier
d'office nous l'avait réclamé la
revanche le retour de gilles verdez a
fait une très belle prestation puisque
gilles verdez avec une liste de
questions il a eu 12 points bravo fils
pour l'instant j'ai eu 15 points c'est
ça va lui arriver n'est qu'elle me plaît
mettez 15 points arrêté 15 points qu'ils
sont les deux autres qualifiés
il reste jean michel mr oui et kelly b
d'amélie bon autant dire que je suis en
finale
[Applaudissements]
entre temps michel maintenant et quel
est celui qui fera plus de 14 points
sera en finale de jacques attali faste à
castel et ensuite il y aura cédric cisr
qui va venir tout à fait ensuite on a
beaucoup de choses vous ai vu que juan
branco qui on est en droit d'attendre
longtemps
là aussi ce sera une revanche entre lui
et moi bocoum agents à temps assurément
après il y aura btp et surtout dans tpm
paix le jeu sachez que je ferai le rôle
du grand frère ce soir car ça ne peut
plus durer
il ya deux chroniqueurs je n'en peux
plus de voir des colis bdd ddd des mots
durs des mots pas d'où des mots pas
minidou ouais voilà donc je veux me
rapprocher je veux savoir pourquoi ils
ne s'aiment pas avant d'avoir des soucis
les tests autant que vous verrez ça
c'est incroyable pour le moment valérie
moi je vous laisse je vais aller faire
un petit tour
d'accord on va continuer donc avec
jean-michel oui bonjour me est ce que tu
es prêt bah oui mais à une balle piquée
mon thème ce que si l'horaire 71 à bats
pas tu veux choisir série sciences
personnage de fiction art années 2000 de
décompter l'improbable technologies non
mais c'est ainsi oui trente secondes
culturel on ya une question sur le mba
est bel et bien il a été créé par un
français le petit neveu de napoléon 1er
[Rires]
c'est bon là c'est jamal c'est quoi
l'histoire recherche les billes a été
créé par le petit neveu napoléon premier
surpris comment un français cet immense
institutions civiles et par un français
oui on s'en bat l'oeil total non non ça
a été hyper important bravo ailleurs
mais c'est vrai j'ai remis à vos
journées très mon chéri oui 14 points à
battre tu fais ton finale face à
benjamin attendant la biologie
d'excellents chiffres disent ah bah oui
pour respirer pendant même temps en
temps c'est trop dur vas-y a foncé c'est
jouable ça se pose le connaissent et
joanes voisine attention top
comment s'appelle l'organisme en charge
de l'exploration spatiale américaine
nasa
oui quelle connexion est la plus rapide
la edge ou la 3g projet oui je suis
comment s'appelle le salaire du pdg de
tesla
non mr john masque comment appelle-t-on
l'internet sans fil
bagdad le wifi oui quel est le principal
composant des batteries de noter de
nombreux tubes quel est le principal
composant des batteries de nos
téléphones fiom oui mais quelle est la
crypto monnaie la plus répandue dans le
monde
la monnaie est le plus répandu pour une
équipe tant monnaie la purée mona le
make-up bikoï que signifie le sigle hd
je rangerai haute définition oui quelle
édition de windows a succédé à windows
95 fenêtre mais cette vie dans 98 des
vrais ou faux les télé led font des
images moche non non mais il faut
qu'elles lettres se trouve entre le 10
et le elles sont un clavier le alpha
entre calvi et comment appelle-t-on la
technologie qui consiste à superposer
des images virtuelles sont de réels des
diapositives sport réalité augmentée
l'unité de calcul de mémoire
d'ordinateur les plus grosses que la
mégane tête giga regardent peut-être
bravo quelle est l'autre nom de la
touche bien ce pacte avait téléphonique
tatum et osaka halte alpha hashtag
je lave
je ne fais aucun commentaire sur l'anti
jeu alors je le dis et pour tout le
monde et ça sera la règle dans son jeu
on peut gens on a le droit de souffler
des conneries d'accord immanente ont
même pas les questionnements dans le
daaka au badhus mans doucement dans les
règles de l'art donc je reformule elle a
le droit d'être un petit [ __ ]
voilà je connais du monde au maroc 8
points pour cent des suisses à la
deuxième manche
donc je ne tolérerai aucune perturbation
pour cette scène c'est là sophie cette
deuxième manche non non deuxième manche
au respect que les personnes venaient
pas parce que tu es là chef du jeu tu
dois admettre tout n'a pas été tué il te
reste années 2000 les arts personnage de
fiction les sciences ou les séries c'est
à dire années 2000 année de nick
à mon avis le cheval a pas besoin que le
choix est judicieux tout est ce que tu
es prête noms tout eu
pour hugh laurie ne pas les écouter de
voilages et sans toit et moi en toi et
moi ouais on y va c'est vrai tu m'as les
tops quel logiciel gratuit de microsoft
utilisait les jeunes pour communiquer
dans les années 2000 m et al oui comment
appeler ton les pantalons larges portes
et très bas les rangs non c'était le
baggy qu'elle danse qui donnait
l'impression de se mettre du gel dans
les cheveux et pendant quelques mois
technique oui le bug de l'an 2000 a fait
planter 500 mille ordinateurs vrai ou
faux
quels artistes voulaient une femme like
you can't we have an les boks comment
s'appelait l'objet qui permettait de se
connecter à internet comme ethernet
les modems son myspace comment
s'appelait l'ami par défaut que tout le
monde avait tablé push donne france télé
diffusé une émission pour enfants dont
les rôles et des marionnettes comment
s'appelait tels les minuteurs micam
munich à louis qui étaient présents des
états unis pendant le 11 septembre
george bush oui comment s'appelait la
soirée m6 se composait de trois séries
tous les samedis soirs très gênés samedi
oui quels sont selon lui d'être tentée
interprétèrent mad love hewitt
et vit à paris s'il tonne est
l'héritière du fondateur des hôtels
hilton vrai ou faux comment s'appelait
la célèbre plateforme de blog lancé par
une radio française
egler je crois qu'on se profile dans
cette finale tant attendue
la revanche de la revanche de la
revanche une finale de konaré durant
l'année 2000 années 2000 et technique
oui mais les deux thèmes les deux thèmes
étaient vraiment j'ai eu un thème très
facile sexy ouais j'suis l'eau c'est
plutôt facile voilà je disais donc à
l'instant avant d'être coupé une finale
de connard versus avec des housses à
rennes on les a toujours respecté
[Rires]
vous êtes juste après cédric 6 heures
arrivée je peux vous dire aujourd'hui on
saura qui sera le tarbes à baba petite
idée donc attention je vous explique
comment ça va se passer cette finale je
vais vous poser des questions
première question facile un point
deuxième question points troisième
question trois points et c'est jusqu'à 5
points par bonne réponse est évidemment
quand on est dans tpm paix sont des
questions qui touchent à la merci
beaucoup a deux qui suivent merci gilles
on va commencer par alors jamin notre
champion normalement c'est le challenger
valérie alors moi je vous dis
aujourd'hui c'est chifoumi voilà
d'accord à l'échec oui comme les
chipeaux me j'ai beau me suis mis mon
bep j
très affecté connecté attention alors
attention donc vous avez compris un
premier vrai nom c'est cyril puis
benjamin etc
j'ai décidé de faire cet été pendant
tout cas final très bien ça vous va
magnifique
cyril première question pour un point en
audiovisuel
que signifie le sigle tnt télévision
télévision numérique terrestre très bien
d'être très très bien comme ça pas vous
le dire
normal demain
ici la liste ici avec voilà qui est
l'actuel présentateur de téléfoot pour
un point et aaron l'actuelle wii
je voudrais une zone riche allez allez
tuer dit ta gueule denis brogniart
mais non ils auront tout avait si bien
sûr vous le savez mon x ou y c'est phil
barney mais non grégoire margotton louis
keita match sur canal + mais j'aime pas
les lampions à deux fois ma mère d'henri
gouard question à deux points alors que
ça c'est facile pour vous dire
franchement cyril ça si vous
correspondez pas vous êtes un connard je
vais me faire traiter toutes les miches
suis habitué à me comprendre pourquoi
en quelle année la chaîne des 8 es
devenu série ça va sur la tête de ma
mère que je sais même pas tuer d'iroise
à toi tu le sais pas puisque tu es plus
intelligent que les autres
nan nan on va devient président algérien
raymond voillat power up cyril alors je
te dire arrêter on était encore un arc
de seine réfléchir en appel qui en prend
ça dans ton dance attend les bras les
patients donc ça on est encore ac de
seine
on n'a pas mis dans la toile
on en 2020 je vais dire franchement je
vais dire je vais dire 2000-2002 mill
valley cherise et un non et non c'est
comme ça c'est une bonne réponse dans la
jambe je suis en plus qu'à les séries
spéciales a procédé au hasard total
je suis désolé benhaim est si dur pour
cyril maintenant benjamin c'est le
moment pour la saison l'écart est très
très fort toujours pour de prompt à
compléter le titre de cette émission de
cuisine animé par laurent mariotte
petits plats en cuisine qui passe la
main et quilicchini yahya yahya c'était
une sorte que dans le public beaucoup
nous fait là il y en a tant que ça fait
quand même trois héros benjamin va
falloir à ces deux questions pour à
trois points pour cyril syrie là en plus
c'est une amie de la famille vous la
connaissez très bien quel est le
véritable prénom de mimie mathy de mimie
mathy oui c'est pas son prénom c'est
mimi c'est votre et on a alors le
prevenar le prénom demi matt mimie mathy
c'est joli c'est bernard ne sais pas je
sais pas mais bon c'est michel et michel
oui mais cette option a oui ça va mais
je crois et gagner celle-là je croyais
mais non mais je crois que des mini
austin bois l'attention parce que là
c'est intéressant pour bajaia rue battre
à mains c'est maintenant qu'il faut
faire le hold up à la main la question
est à trois points si tu vas revenir à
égalité
c'est maintenant inquiète elle cherche
donc normalement d'un professionnel des
médias un animateur chevronné tu vas
quand même d'aller télé 25 ans 25 ans tu
es tu devrais pouvoir répondre à cette
question d'image calcule combien
d'animateurs faire constater que céder
pour animer le jeu
les amoureux tous dans la merde t'es un
connard voilà la vase il énumère avec
tes yeux
alors on prend en compte dans l'actuelle
oui oui combien encore tant à coeur à
l'efi sa foi et 4 40 et 4 il avait
raison c'est 4 il y avait reichmann
d'alluré chômage
la faune à fond j'ai mis l'annoncé d'un
verdict et jean louis lafon attention
aux questions
bah si je martinez et 4.6 cyril gagne
ses membres non non c'est pas encore
mort est passé chez moi c'est gai savoir
voulons aussi attention s'ils n'ont ils
pas encore google
quelle saison de plus belle la vie est
actuellement diffusée sur france 3 nous
aurons plus belle la vie on allait à la
con 20e de ces personnes souffrent les
frères ils ont deux cent cinquante ans
les acteurs affichent alors il arrive à
moi je vais dire vite je veux dire la
20e saison
non non et la 16e 16 ans et 16e 6 heures
bal et tout était déjà là on n'est pas
loin des mauvais il est mauvais il est
mauvais mais je vous emmerde a330 054
attention à quatre points mais bon allez
vous prendre matin il fallait allez
vas-y bien assez tôt à tapas ou
t'inquiéter consacre au toit note aucune
personne maghrébine quelle série fait un
record d'audience sur france 3 avec plus
de a fait un record sur france 3 avec
plus de 9 millions de téléspectateurs
plutôt dans l'eau non non
quelle série c'est fini ça m'a pris mais
n'a pas brillé mais qu'elle sera trop
tard
louis la brocante bah oui
on de téléphone vrai quoi louis la
brocante tu avais pas non plus vous font
mal à moi m'a pas posé la question
alors alors tu vas faire tu vas voir ue
et le mystère du viager
non tu viendras d'accord un million à un
truc de fou balle et alors là alors
attention j'ai pas encore perdre un
événement commercial à cinq points ouais
tu reçois ce jouet la série c'était si
tu remportes la question c'est bon ça y
est c'est plus sinon benjamin peut à
nouveau repas la tv sur comment ces
villes
question 5 points quelle est la seule
émission de télé réalité qu'a animée
faustine bollaert
elle animait une émission de télé
réalité pas facile je sais ce que
c'était c'était je ne me souviens pas
boufbowl que des pauvres est-ce que tout
valider ce que tu veux ça c'est par
rising star
non non non non vous êtes bon c'est
carré viiip c'était dilemme pas du tout
cas arrivé les pistes il a les a fire à
taradeau attention attention parce que
les dilemmes stefan mais c'est pas ça
que ça a duré 2 2 dans deux semaines
maintenant
non ça attire les amarres semaines
benjamin non non j'ai des doutes face à
marc garde moi ouais je suis là si je
suis là hop hop hop hop hop à damas pour
20 points là alors tu peux rien dire on
tue bat encore pour la deuxième fois
consécutive savine et illumine oui je
lui ministre la map est une aubaine
toiture
alors c'est parti en france il est mort
vieux a remporté la première saison
the voice bon pas remis facile
c'est à rome et de souvient du nom à la
voile a remporté la première saison de
de voice c'est un fart phare cannes et
l'oubli mais je vais lui dire qu entre
je vais évoluer en 2012 annonce était
une mauvaise reb en 2012 il avait su 12
ans kenji frais des cambistes est fan
prison
mais rien vu stéphane lambert
[Musique]
les moules du joran mettrai mon titre en
jeu lundi
bah voilà parce que super pippo est
d'accord